one two three four five six one two
three four five six seven
Wow it's actually good yeah namaste my
name is ABBA and I've been learning but
not him for the past 20 years now it's
been fun learning and understanding this
beautiful dance form and also our
teaching a little I think it needs like
flexibility with your eyes you have to
do this I really hope the woman doesn't
yell at me when you like start with
Bharat Natyam you have to start with the
Namaskar right then left then you go
down and then to your eyes and then you
come back up okay just come back up oh
my god you can't come back up can you
okay this is why you don't skip leg day
and gestures is is this is this no this
oh okay this is not how you sit like
this okay so one left yourself sitting
like that one
two one no no no not that fast you do
the neck thingy and you do the half
thingy and you do your facial
expressions and do the three patacas
together at the same time yes it is
something that any human being can
manage with 1/2 an extra head bob is not
something that I asked for did I
open/close pay you
that's the pay yeah but that they
continue so we're gonna do a piece on
Krishna and Radha so your Krishna of
course okay so your Raja am Radha and
she is Krishna Radha is actually um in
the jungle and she is waiting for
Krishna and Krishna is late one to see
the creeper to rock this side but where
is is Krishna and then she sees that
he's um whatever playing Garba with
other women on seeing that she is
furious and she leaves when she sees you
you ask your friends to go away
oh thanks and now you you've seen in and
then you were going and then Krishna's
which is going to try really hard to win
her
and you are like I'm really z-wave I do
this do please like it's like hello
school school yeah okay the very scope
of the dance is mind-blowing so I
thought it was a really girly thing and
turns out it's not like that a lot of
people think that guys can't dance or
guys can't do classical Indian classical
dances but that's untrue we are going to
just do the Namaskar together so